ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نفت وزاره الاعلام السوريه اليوم
استهداف موكب الرئيس بشار الاسد لدى توجهه
لاداء صلاه العيد بدمشق بينما قالت
المعارضه ان الموكب استهدف براجمات
الصواريخ وقذائف الهاون وقد ظلت صلاه
الاسد للعيد وسط الظروف الامنيه المتغيره
منذ اندلاع ثوره الخامس عشر من اذار مثار
جدل بين روايات النظام وتعقيدات معارضين
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
امكانيه حدوث الهجوم الذي استهدف الاسد
بين نفس الحكومه سوريه وتاكيد المعارضه
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه للهجوم في ضوء
السجال القائم في المعارك على الارض
وقبل البدء بمناقشه هذا الموضوع نتوقف مع
تقرير التاليه
التلفزيون السوري نقل صور الرئيس السوري
يدخل مسجد انس بن مالك في اخر لحظه لاداء
صلاه العيد والمصلون واقفون الصور جاءت
بعد تاكيدات مقاتلي المعارضه وتحديدا لواء
الاسلام الذي ينشط في دمشق استهدافه
الموكب الرئاسي وقوع اصابات نحن لم يستهدف
المنطقه ال اه الموجود فيها الا عندما
تذكرنا بانه لا يوجد عناصر مدنيه في تلك
المنطقه تؤكد المعارضه استهداف موكب الاسد
في شارع المالكي الذي كان مقررا مرور
الموكب الرئاسي عبره نحو المسجد ولم تغفل
عن ذكر نوعيه القذائف وعددها الذي بلغ
اثنتي عشره وقد سارع وزير الاعلام السوري
الى تكذيب الخبر واعتبره عاليا من الصحه
تاخر اداء الاسد صلاه العيد ساعه من الزمن
مقارنه ب توقيت صلاه العيد في دمشق وحسب
الصور التي بثها التلفزيون السوري ظهرت
كلمه مباشر الا انها لم تستمر طويلا
بينما اكد عضو مجلس الشعب السوري لسان
خليل ان صلاه العيد بثت على التلفزيون
الرسمي في موعدها
الامنيه الذي
بلغت مده الصور التي نقلها التلفزيون
السوري اثنتين وعشرين دقيقه
وقد دار حديث صغير للاسد مع احمد بدر
الدين حسون مفتي الجمهوريه قبيل تكبيره
الاحرام كما زاغت عيناه فى الركعه الاولى
نحو كاميرا التلفزيون
وما يلاحظ ايضا هو عدم اطالته الحديثه مع
الملتفين حوله بعد اداء الصلاه وانصرافه
على عجله وكانت صور مشابهه لصلاه عيد
الفطر العام الماضي ظهر فيها الاسد وهو
يسلم وينهي قبيل تسليم الامام وكان فيها
مستعجلا للخروج ايضا
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من دمشق
زهران علوش قائد لواء الاسلام
ومن عمان الدكتور فائق في استاذ علم النفس
والاجتماع ومعنا في الاستوديو العميد صفوت
الزيات الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه نبدا من عندك زهران علوش لو
تعطينا تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه العمليه التي
قلتم انها استهدفت موكب الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد اليوم
هذه
دقيقه
على اهدافها
الاحصائيه دقيقه
سيد ظهرا من الذي استهدف الممكن ان تمام
لي وتحرير الشام ام لان هناك يعني اه اه
تبني من اكثر من جهه لهذه العمليه
نعم هناك اكثر من جهه استهدفت الممكن
لما وصلتنا المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
الدقيقه استاذتنا الممكن بصواريخ كاتيوشا
وهناك ايضا جهات اخرى استهدفت الممكن
المدافع الان
الجهود الممكن مع ان التنسيق في هذه
المساله كان شبه معدوم لان هذه العمليات
تقوم على
ولكن الذي
انك انت اذا كان التنسيق ربما متعذرا بين
المجموعات المختلفه كما قلت كيف اعددتهم
لمثل هكذا عمليه بهذه الدقه ويعني على هذا
المستوى
اه ليس المتعذر هو التواصل مع نحن على
مقربه كثيره من
القصر الجمهوري ومناطق المالكي وقد من
ايام
التي كان يذهب لتنفيذ
هو موجود على مشارف دمشق
على مباشر الان اننا نحن نمشي
طويلا
ولا يمشي المسيرات
بطرق واساليب كبيره الواقع انه
والقوه
لقواتنا
بينما رجع يتخذها اسلوبا من التفاهم
العراقيين الاستمرار
كبيره وعندنا
من اجهزه الاتصال من الممكن ان التواصل
مراقبه الوضع عن
الى ان هناك لدينا
عدد كبير من قوات ال استطاع منتشره في قلب
مدينه دمشق
الحساسه ونتعاون
العوائل الشرفاء الذين يصلون في المناطق
الحساسه
وزير الاعلام السوري عمران الزعبي نفى
بشكل قاطع ان تكون مثل هذه العمليه قد
حدثت زاد وقال ان الرئيس السوري كان يقود
سيارته بنفسه وذهب الى صلاه العيد وبالفعل
عدم اظهر عبر التلفزيون السوري ولم يصب
باي اذى اذن ما لاثبات ان هذه العمليه
حدثت بالفعل
اه نحن في الحقيقه وزير الاعلام
ولكن الواقع الذي
مع علمي العالم جميعا
الاسلام
الكاتيوشا وكذلك هناك مجموعات اخواننا
العاملين في اه
الحرب النظام استهدفوا الموقف
الان هذه القضايا
وزير الاعلام ان
ابقى معي فائق
زهران علوش نتحول الى عمان ومعنا من هناك
الدكتور فائق فرج دكتور فائق ربما تابعت
الصور التي الصور المباشره الذي كان بثها
التلفزيون السوري الرسمي ل اه اداء الرئيس
السوري صلاه العيد كيف بذلك الرجل
يعني يعني يعني
اه اه عمليه ال اه المرسل والمتلقي عمليه
المرسل والمتلقي الحركه اللي بتظهر من ال
ال الجسد وهذا يعني علم من العلوم الحديثه
اه تعبر عن حاله من اه الانزعاج او نوع من
القلق او التوتر اه موجوده في داخل الجسد
ولكنه لا يظهر مباشره احيانا المرسل اه
حركات معينه المتلقي
لاستحداث شيء اول عمل نتيجه معينه او
تتابع امر معين لكن الا حات اللي بتحصل
بهذه الطريقه بيدل على انه في شيء سابق
حدث يعني في في اه سلوك معين حصل على هذا
السلوك الحالي
الرئيس السوري يعبر عن ان الرجل ربما خارج
من محاوله اغتيال
انا انا انا يعني جانب سيكولوجيا جانب
نفسي حتى انا بدون ما ابحث في هذا الجانب
الطلبات شهاده الخبر سابقا وشفت حركه
عيونه الى اليمين والى اليسار ويطلع
بطريقه لك ليش يعني هو بالصلاه يعد السلام
والصراع الى ارتباط مباشر من نظام معين
انا استغربت من هذه الحركه
بيدل على انه هو مش ثابت على اه بامان
يعني من الشعر بالامان يعني ما عنده عدم
استقرار فبالتالي ظهرت هذه الحركات اه على
الواقع وعلى العينين و كان متسرعا كان
يريد ان يخرج
الدكتور سائق ان الرجل اصلا يعني هو ليس
في وضع طبيعي اه اه الرجل اصلا يعني يعيش
في اه اه بلد فيه توتر كبير فيه ثوره عليه
اه اه وايضا هناك لا تنسى يعني اه ربما
رغبه الكاميرات واه الصلاه هذه التي
ينقلها التلفزيون بشكل مباشر اليست
الكاميرا ت وكاميرات
يعني هذه انا ب ب تجنبها اما انه يعيش في
بلد في
طبيعي اضطرابات وفي اه ج شو فيه قتال وفي
قنابل وفي صواريخ هذا الكلام صحيح يعني
هذا عامل مؤثر لكن بس ال ال الحركات اه
بالصلاه تدل على انه الاشي اللي حصل قريب
يعني مش مش بعيد يعني ايش قريب يرتبط
بالحركات الامنيه
واتصور انه يمكن ان تعرض لهذا الهجوم انا
بتصور ارتباط سيكولوجي بالواقع اللي حصل
عميد صفوت الزيات بناءا على موازين القوى
الموجوده اليوم على الارض والتي انتم لم
بها جدا اه اه ماذا يعني مثل هذا الهجوم
لو كان حدث واحد يمكن له ان اه اذا ما
تصورنا اه انه منذ اكثر من اسبوعين شكل ال
جبهه التحرير العاصمه وبدات المعارضه
المسلحه تنتقل لاول مره من الغوطه الشرقيه
في اتجاها الى داخل دمشق بمعنى ان لدينا
على مدى اسبوعين قتال يتم في دراسات
العباسيين وفي ساحه العباسيين هذا الحدث
وكانه يتم على مسافه 2 كيلو متر او اكثر
قليلا من موقع الحدث الذي تم الان بمعنى
ان المعارضه المسلحه الا نتقاتل في دمشق
اليوم وكان يوم عيد هناك قصف جوي للقبول
جوبر وبرزه هناك ضغوط ومناطق اخرى احنا
نحن نتحدث عن عاصمه يتم فيها استخدام
المدفعيات من فوق الجبل قاسيون و يتم فيها
استخدام طائرات القتال سابقه في الملاح
وليس للك نحن امام وكانه منطقه عمليات
يعني بكل ماتعني منطقه عمليات اه في في في
في دمشق اذن هذا الامر ليس مستغربا
المعارضه المسلحه ليست الحال الذي كانت
عليه عندما اقتحم الضغط العتيبه في نصف
ابريل الماضي وقال اليوم قطع خطوط الامداد
عن اه والسلاح والامدادات عن المعارضه
المسلحه في الغوطه وكتبت الصحف
الاسرائيليه ان معركه دمشق امامها عشرين
يوم ربما الامر
تماما الان عندما نتكلم عن يوم ايدو عندما
نتكلم ان الجميع يدرك ان هناك قصر الروضه
الذي في مكتب الرئاسيه الرئيسيه المهاجرين
هناك قصر تشرين هناك القصر الرئاسي اذن
هناك يعني طرق محدده اه اه اه اه اه توجه
الرئيس الى هذا المسجد الرئيسي اذن هي طرق
محدده بصوره او باخرى وبالتالي حديث على
ان هم اعترضوا الموكب وكان هناك موقف في
طريق اخر هذا امر منطقي للغايه لكن اه اه
اه اه مسائل القصف سواء باستخدام الهاون
او بس تواريخ الكاتيوشا اعتقد انه لم تكن
اه يعني بالغه الدقه ولكن اعتقد ان
الرساله وصلت بمعنى الان موكب الرئيس
بهذا الامر اه اه بعد فاصل قصير
نواصل بعده النقاش اذن اه
اه نعود اذن الى هذه الحلقه من جديد اعود
الى زهران علوش قائد لواء الاسلام زهران
علوش اه زهران علوش كيف اه
اعود واسالك عن كيفيه تحضير كم لهذه
العمليه هل اعتبرت فقط على اه موكب الرئيس
ام ان كان لها اه ربما تحضير مسبق
وبشكل اه اه تكتيكي اكثر
جيدا
حيثيات العمليه
انه
كما قال تماما
كما كنا في البدايه نفسه ضعيفه
تقاوم
ولكننا تبارك وتعالى نحن الان عندنا قوات
استطاع وعندنا كثير الصواريخ
ممارسه طويله جدا
على العدو في المنطقه وعندنا اه اه قوه
استخبارات
قويه منتشره في العاصمه حتى اننا
على اه اخترقنا كثير من المراكز الامنيه
التي تدفع عشان على المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الحقيقه والتي شرحها اكثر
من مره وبناء على
روما كلها للصواريخ بناء على المعلومات
الوارده لنا من
اه
تماما
الذي رفضها اه
نقول بشكل اه كامل يعني ا ولكن هذا
الاعمى الذي
عظيمه بين اه تتميز كثيرين
قائد لواء الاسلام زهران علوش حدثنا من
دمشق ام
ما هي الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمثل هذه
العمليه عمليه استهداف موكب بشار الاسد
وقد تكون يعني يعني تعني اه يعني هذا
الامر انه استهداف مباشر الرئيس السوري
استراتيجيا
اعتقد ان هذا نمط الحروب الجديده حروب
نسميها حروب الجيل الرابع لن يترك الخصم
والقسم الاخر لم يذكر لن يترك الاخر في
نسق من الانساق مطمئن بمعنى الان هم
احرزوا على سبيل المثال سيطروا على مطار
من في اقصى الشمال الان ربما يقاتلون
كتيبه الهجانه اه في منطقه الجمرك القديم
في درعا الان يتعاملون مع المراكز
القياديه والسياسيه القياديه السياسيه
والعسكريه العليا في قلب العاصمه ساحه
الامويين حيث مبنى رئاسه الاركان الرئيس
ذاته وهو يتوجه حتى في بعض المناسبات
الاقتراب من القصور الرئاسيه بمعنى
الاهميه قيمته انه يضع الخصم في مستويات
التكتيكيه والعمليه والاستراتيجيه كامله
تحتضن هو لا يترك القياده مستريحه انت لا
تشاهد الرئيس ليس هناك متحدث رسمي يحدثنا
يوميا ماذا حدث لا توجد قياده عسكريه
بالمعنى ال ال ال المفروض اه عن كل اليوم
الخميس الماضي نحن تابعنا بدقه زيارته
الاداريه اداريه هو يذهب في يوم عيد الجيش
العربي السوري اللي هو كان جيشنا جميعا هو
ذهب في مناسبه وحاول ان يجتمع مع عسكريين
وفي اداريه المنطقه التي بعمليات عدد
الجنود عندما لن يزيد عن عشره محيط بينما
كان هناك حجم كبير و احداث كبيره من الحرس
الخاص انا دائما اسال اذا كان رئيس الدوله
يتواجد في منطقه عسكريه ما هي الحاجه لحرس
خاص هل تامينه من جنوده نفسهم ام ان الامر
اصبح مربك او مربكا للغايه هذه هي الصوره
التي ربما نقلت يوم الخميس الماضي وجاءت
ترجمتها اليوم في اول
يبقى في اطار الصوره ونسال الدكتور فائق
فراج استاذ علم النفس والاجتماع دكتور
فائق كنت تتحدث عن ان الصوره التي ظهر
فيها بشار الاسد اه يعني اه لم يبدو فيها
وكانه متماسك بدا وكانه بالفعل خارج من
عمليه الاغتيال اود ان اسالك عن امور اخرى
لاحظناها يعني اه هو بقى اه فلا وظهر عبر
التلفزيون لاثنين وعشرين دقيقه لم يطل
الحديث مع الحمص مين ولا مع الحاضرين كانت
هناك اه حركات غريبه في الرجلين اثناء
اداء الصلاه كل هذا ماذا يعني
يعني يعني
برجلين او الحركات بالايدي او بالاصابع او
الجماعات بالراس او بالعيون هذه تعبر عن
نوع من القلق والتوتر او ما زي ما تفضلت
سابقا نقلت ان الكاميرات ممكن يكون لها
تاثير هذا يعني رئيس دوله يعني هي ما واجه
اه كاميرات ويا ما عم لقاءات دوليه
لكن احنا نتكلم عنه وضع
فكانت تاثير مباشر كانه حصلت يعني حصل الى
شيء قبل ما ياتي الى المسجد هذا التفسير
سيكون الى تفسيرها من النفس لهذا السلوك
وبالتالي اه هذه الحركات بدات ظاهره عليه
يعني كان فيه نوع من من من السرعه عنده
فيه حتى اطلع على حركه عيون وعنده الى
اليمين الى اليسار ثم ننظر الى على بينما
المصليه يعرف انه يصلي
بصلاته
الله سبحانه وتعالى الى ال اه الى الامام
هو كان فيه عندي نوع من التوتر والقلق
وهذا الكلام يعني منذ بدات ال الثوره
بسوريا لكن اليوم تظهر هذه الحركات نتيجه
وجود شيء قريب جدا اه في هذا اليوم ا وقبل
اه ساعات معينه اثرت عليه بهذا التاثير
السلبي وجعلت اه في وضع غير ثابت
كل سالت هذا السؤال زهران علوش ربما لم
يشا ان يجيبني يعني اه تحضير ال مثل هكذا
عمليه هل يعتمد فقط على الرصد كما كان
يحدثنا ام انه يستوجب اختراق استخباراتي
الدائره ضيقه اه بلا شك هذا امر جيد
للغايه دعيني اقول الخميس الماضي الخميس
الماضي تحديدا دون مرات اكبر مخازن
للصواريخ والذخيره في حي وادي الذهب في
الجنوب الشرقي اه لحماس وكان السؤال
الكبير كيف وصل المعارضه المسلحه لهذه
المعلومات وكيف قصفت بهذه الدقه بعدها
شاهدنا يوم الاحد الماضي السيطره على
مستودعات ضخمه بالذخيره في منطقه القلمون
ومنطقه القانون بها الفرقه الثالثه
المدرعه اقوى الفرق التي مازالت ب عافيتها
وكفاءتها القتاليه الان هذا الاختراق
السريع الذي تم في اللاذيقيه والذي جاء
مفاجئا والذي تم السيطره على اكثر من عشر
قرى كل هذا ومع مع العمليه التي تمت اليوم
كل هذه المؤشرات تقول ان هناك اختراقا
استخباراتيا
اصبحت المعارضه المسلحه تتمتع به وتصل كما
قلت من قبل الى مفاصل القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه
في الدوله وهذا هو نمط الحروب الحديثه
لم يعد هناك جزء من منظومه خصم الا وتكون
تحت ضغط مستمر اليوم الرئيس السوري تحت
ضغط حديث اه يوم الاثنين الماضي في حفل
الافطار اننا نقترب من الانتصار اننا في
حرب شعبيه وقبلها قال ان العمليات
العسكريه للجيش العربي السوري ستدرس في
المراكز البحثيه ثم نجد من ال من ال ال ال
اللاذقيه ونجد اه
درعه ونجد اه مناطق اخرى من ست خان العسل
شيء ما اصبح الرجل يعاني منه واخطر
الاشياء التي يعاني منها دائما رئيس
وقائدا على قوات مسلحه انه لا يحصل على
شيء من الميدان بمعنى افاق كبير
كل ما يقوله النظام ومؤيدون عن اه تقدم
استراتيجي يحصل على الارض من الخسائر الى
حمص الى غيره
القصير كان استثناءا ولكن اين اين ريف
دمشق اين المحاوله اليوم
لدينا الكثير من الوقت اه برايك استهداف
بشار الاسد هل ما زال بشار الاسد هو عنوان
هذه الازمه في سوريا بعد اكثر من سنتين
على الثوره بعد كل الامور على الارض ام هل
رحيله او الغائه من الصوره الامور قد يحل
جزء كبير لاننا في النظم الشموليه ونظم
الديكتاتوريه عاده ما يمثل راس النظام
الجزء الاكبر من مكونات النظام بعد ذلك
يتفكك نعم صحيح انه نظام يرتبط على قاعده
طائفيه ولكن يظل في النهايه ان القاعده
الطائفيه من الممكن ان تصل الى امور
وتسويات اخرى كثيره عندما يطرح بهذا الراس
وبالتالي اه اه ادبيات كثيره من الولايات
المتحده في الاونه الاخيره تتحدث عن امل
في انقلاب عسكري او تغيير ما في راس
السلطه هذا ما يراهن عليه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر العميد صفوت الزيات الخبير في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه والشكر
موصول ايضا لك دكتور فائق في الرجل استاذ
علم النفس والاجتماع حدثنا من عم وشارك
معنا ايضا في الحلقه زهران علوش قائد لواء
الاسلام من دمشق اشكركم جزيل الشكر بهذا
ننتهي من هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]